c'est le Rhino routier ça policier reste
les sirène il y en a partout
sur les plages
j'ai vachement confiance en vous on y va
on est parti on est aux orphelières à
Valras-Plage et on va collecter des
déchets dans le but de sensibiliser la
jeunesse
[Musique]
et le problème c'est que on se rend pas
compte que quand le jette même à midi là
on voit public ça passe dans le pluvial
le pluvialiste verse dans le fleuve ou
la rivière et au final dès qu'il y a des
vagues et tu vas et on arrive à les
retrouver voilà ça dure longtemps ça y
est le sac est plein
en un quart d'heure 20 minutes
tellement
il y en a tous les jours et selon les
marées selon le ressens et en même temps
c'est encourageant plus tu envoies plus
tu as envie d'en ramasser
8 millions de tonnes par an plastique
dans les océans
si on sensibilise pas si on fait rien
dans 50 ans il y aura plus de plastique
que de poissons c'est un des fléaux pour
les mammifères marins parce que ils
prennent le plastique
et c'est tout
il faisait pareil
c'est kilos on était sur la digue donc
ça fait un moment qui a pas eu d'épisode
méditerranéen mais on voit que les
déchets sont coincés dans les rochers
qu'on galère les enlever
on a un peu galéré d'ailleurs on n'a pas
terminé les câbles là
effectivement bloqué sous les rochers
ouais cordage cordage filet câble je les
ai très très bien vendus
1 kg aussi
bravo bravo à tous
que ce soit sur une plage dans une rue
vallée dans la montagne n'importe où une
anomalie en fait c'est que d'un coup un
bout de plastique une canette une
bouteille un truc qui traîne un truc qui
ne va pas avec la nature un truc qui
n'est pas naturel immédiatement je
ramasse immédiatement j'ai le réflexe je
le mets dans ma fouille je le mets dans
une poubelle je vais dans un sac
conscience là
c'est réservé toujours
eu éduqué comme ça non parce que moi je
suis né en 72 ça veut dire qu'en gros en
72 je pense qu'en 72 un adulte comme un
ado comme un enfant qui prenait une
barre chocolatée il ouvrait son sachet
il a balancé il fume une clope il l'a
jeté il ouvre une canette il balance
je pense qu'on se disait la nature peut
toute façon
peut le prendre il y a aucun problème
elle s'en arrangera et puis un moment on
a dit mais tu sais qu'il faut 100 ans
pour que ça se ça disparaisse pour le
coup on rattrape nos conneries on est
enfin nous moi j'ai 5 ans on a le
sentiment un peu de rattraper nos
conneries projets